it has just been announced that a new
movie is being made about the infamous
former Mayor of Toronto Rob Ford there
he is oh that guy yeah yeah this was
this is real news it just broke
just today as you'll probably recall a
couple years ago mayor Ford was
constantly in the news both in Canada
and internationally with countless
stories of him being publicly
intoxicated even smoking crack on camera
everybody was talking about this guy so
you know big deal well anyway it just
come out that British actor Damian Lewis
from billions and homeland is going to
be playing the role of the disgraced
mayor yeah now apparently I don't know
why you're laughing this is all true but
thank you because they're laughs and
I'll take them but anyway here's the bad
part apparently a lot of Canadians are
really upset that Hollywood's making a
movie about Rob Ford okay a guy who made
a laughingstock out of their country
they just want to move on they're like
enough is enough no one is more worked
up about this than one of our shows
Canadian writers and former Toronto
resident Levi mcdougal he is asked if he
could come out for a moment to deliver a
strongly-worded statement on behalf of
all Canadians I passed him on the way
into work and I've never seen him more
angry ya know this is a whole new side
of Levi pure rage and it's something he
feels he needs to address so please
welcome our only Canadian writer Levi
MacDougall
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks thanks cloning hey Hollywood
my noble country has a rich in fabled
history filled with countless heroes and
heroines whose stories deserve to be
told but instead of going with legend of
the ice Gordie Howe er war of 1812
heroine Laura Secord you picked buzz
cutted Zamboni Rob Ford a guy that the
world in Canada was just starting to
forget well not on my watch so on behalf
of all my fellow countrymen and women
please pay very close attention to what
I'm about to say look come on it Levi
Levi please just relax relax and take a
deep breath
not today Cornyn this Yukon grizzly just
woke up from hibernation he's got an
appetite Levi tone it down be reasonable
it's it's too late Andy this canoes left
this station and there's no stopping it
okay if it's any consolation Levi
award-winning actor Damian Lewis is
gonna be playing Rob Ford pretty boy
Damian Lewis terrible choice you might
as well curl on my hockey rink Rob Ford
didn't look like this he looked like
this
and he didn't he didn't hold umbrellas
like this he held them like this and
this isn't a mustache this is a mustache
Levi please you're out of control with
rage plus producers have assured people
that Damian Lewis will look exactly like
Rob Ford through the use of heavy makeup
and prosthetics prosthetic heck that's
even worse you just cracked open a warm
one yeah you can't just put makeup on
anyone and call them a Canadian that's
that's called maple face and and it's
offensive
alright listen I think Levi's out of
control can we get security in here I've
never seen him like this okay come with
me mister okay look I'm really sorry
Conan I can't control myself when the
Hulk comes out
[Applause]
you